you can't miss it the ever given is
still stuck
firm and dominating the landscape around
it
for the locals but a real problem for
the authorities
despite the multinational rescue effort
the giant ship
isn't budging heavier tugs have been
brought in to try and shift it
and the dredger is removing sand and
stones from under the ship
as each day passes more cargo ships and
tankers
stack up at either end of the canal and
the impact on global commerce
worsens much longer and it really will
start to be felt around the world
vice admiral mohammad was in charge of
the suez canal
until a few months ago he's now advising
the salvage teams
you have to have a salvage plan
and some equipment
everything because this is very huge
ship
and about 18 000
container it's very
high number and i think our teamwork
you succeed high tides over the next few
days will help
but containers might need to be lifted
off to lighten the ship
already they found a special crane in
alexandria
and they are preparing the crane now
and there is another ship will come to
be alongside the ship
and take the the some container from the
first one
to the second round and when do you
think that will happen
after two days in the crane and the
ships will be here
they'll be working all night to pull it
free but as we enter
a second week there's no guarantee the
ship
will be released soon aleister bunker
sky news
egypt